SPEAKER: When approaching
the architecture of your data
warehouse, it's important
to understand the constructs
of the services you'll use.
So what are folders,
projects, and data sets,
and how do they come
together to support
warehousing fundamentals like
security and cost management?
On today's episode of
"BigQuery Spotlight,"
we're talking about the
BigQuery resource model
and giving you our top tips for
structuring your own resources.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's get started
by talking about how
BigQuery fits into the Google
Cloud resource hierarchy.
An organization is the root node
of the Google Cloud resource
model.
It represents a company,
probably the one you work for,
and it's linked to a domain
through a Google Workspace
or Cloud Identity account.
An organization
resource isn't required
to get started with BigQuery,
but it is recommended.
With an organization, resources
like BigQuery data sets
or tables can be
centrally controlled
by organization
administrators, instead
of solely being owned by the
employee that creates them.
Within an organization,
you create billing accounts
that specify who actually pays
for Google Cloud resources.
You can also create
folders, which
offer an additional grouping
mechanism for resources.
Folders often represent
business units or legal entities
within your company and make it
easier to organize and monitor
resource utilization.
Folders also act as a
policy inheritance point.
Access rules granted on a
folder are automatically
inherited by all
projects and folders
included in that folder.
Now, let's go a
little bit deeper.
Within an organization
or a folder,
you can create
projects, which form
the basis for using BigQuery.
Projects are tied to a
single billing account, which
means that if different teams
need to be billed individually
for their BigQuery usage, they
would need their own projects,
and additional
billing accounts would
need to be created at
the organization level.
Let's take a look at how this
resource hierarchy is reflected
in the Cloud Console,
where you interact with
and analyze your
data in BigQuery.
In BigQuery, projects are
kind of like databases
in other systems.
But here, you can
have separate projects
for storing and
analyzing your data.
When opening up the console,
you can see your projects
on the left-hand side,
with the data stored nested
beneath each project name.
All storage costs will be billed
to the associated projects
here.
Even with data stored
across different projects,
you can analyze it
together by joining tables
in a single query.
At the top of the console,
you can see the project where
your query will actually run.
All compute costs will
be billed to this project
and its associated
billing account.
Speaking of billing, BigQuery
offers two different pricing
models.
Projects with
on-demand pricing are
charged for the number of
bytes processed by each query.
But with this model, there
are per-project limitations
and quotas that are
important to consider.
The other option is
flat-rate pricing,
where customers purchase compute
capacity to handle workloads.
With this model,
reservations can
be assigned at the organization,
folder, or project levels
to handle jobs
within that resource.
On-demand pricing is great for
getting started with BigQuery,
but as your consumption
grows, flat-rate offers
scalable compute with
predictable pricing.
Great-- so now back
to the resource model.
So far, we've
discussed resources
applicable to all Google
Cloud deployments,
but now, we'll focus on
resources specific to BigQuery.
Within a project,
data sets are used
to house, organize,
and control access
to tables, views, routines,
and machine-learning models.
They're similar to
schemas in other systems.
When you create a data set, you
choose a geographic location
where your data will be stored.
BigQuery offers a variety
of regions and multi-regions
for your data
residency requirements.
However, you can't
query across data
that lives in
different locations,
so make sure to
plan accordingly.
Data sets also store metadata.
You can create
descriptions and labels,
which can be viewed
in the console
or used as tabs for monitoring.
You can also find details
about each one of your BigQuery
resources by querying
the information schema.
But data sets aren't the
only BigQuery resource
belonging to projects.
Other concepts, like
connections and jobs,
can be found here as well.
We'll cover more detail on
these in the next few videos.
Now that you understand
the top-level containers
of the BigQuery resource
model, let's talk
about some common ways users
structure their deployments.
First off, some
BigQuery architects
choose to create a common
storage project that is queried
in other compute projects.
In this case, a centralized
data platform team
can also create pipelines
in a storage project
to actually ingest data
from different sources.
You can think of this storage
project as a data lake
or a storage repository that
holds a bunch of raw data.
Then, each department can
have their own project
for querying the data,
saving results, and creating
aggregate views.
You can think of these
projects as data marts,
or a repository
of summarized data
collected for analysis on a
unit within the organization,
for example, the
sales department.
This structure is
especially useful
when departments want to
be individually billed
for their queries,
or if queries need
to be run in separate
projects to avoid
per project limitations.
Another option is to
do the reverse, where
each department creates and
manages their own storage
project to house their raw data.
Aggregate tables or
transformations of the raw data
are then stored in a
centralized data warehouse
project where analysts can
read and query the data.
This structure allows for
project-level access controls
against raw data and offers
a simple data access layer
for connecting business
intelligence tools to BigQuery.
Many BigQuery administrators
use some combination
of these two structures.
When deciding on your
own architecture,
you should be asking
questions like,
how often will analysts
be running queries
against these data sets?
How should storage
and compute be billed
to our different departments?
And who should have
access to what data?
We hope this overview gets you
well on your way to designing
your BigQuery architecture.
For more guidance
on getting started
with BigQuery or the
BigQuery resource model,
check out the links below.
Thanks for joining us today
for "BigQuery Spotlight."
Watch out for the next episode,
and remember, stay curious.
[MUSIC PLAYING]